put Inhumans into a hibernation state to
make interplanetary journeys has been a
staple of science fiction films like
aliens and passengers some people think
it might one day become a reality and
even a solution to get people to Mars
the only problem humans don't hibernate
but Bears do in ways that we might one
day emulate it's not unique to one
particular class of mammals and I think
as long as those pieces are there in
humans then we could translate that into
a situation where hibernation could be
induced he studies hibernation in bears
we talked to him about what human
hibernation might be like and the ways
it could help us hurtle through space or
cure our illnesses so tell us a little
bit about what's interesting
physiologically about bears and
hibernation Wow where to start
everything no it's it's really quite an
amazing physiological state where the
bears can survive for months without
eating or drinking their body
temperature when they're hibernating
doesn't go that low it only drops to
about thirty to thirty four degrees
centigrade versus 37 but if you compare
that to a ground squirrel they may drop
their temperature to zero or sometimes
even below zero they still reduce their
metabolic rate how much oxygen they
consume how much energy they actually
consume by seventy five percent which is
very similar to what's happening in a
rodent they have normal sleep-wake
cycles they're much less active but they
still do stand up and they may move
around their den so they're actually
some of us in the bear world think that
bears are actually the most advanced
hibernator based on all of those
abilities when you're studying
hibernation in bears what does that
actually look like so I'm fortunate that
I belong to a group at Washington State
University we have an actual research
facility with the sole purpose of trying
to understand everything about bear
physiology bear ecology
and wildlife preservation we have these
captive animals some which were raised
in captivity others which came from the
wild as problem bears and so those
animals are hibernating right now and
what we can do is we can go into those
dens and we can sedate them and we can
take blood samples for example we can
take a small tissue biopsy to to gather
the cells that we need for our cell
culture work we can do a variety of
physiological measurements that we want
is there also a world in which we learn
how to hibernate as humans because we
know that hibernation evolved in
different species over different periods
of time it's not unique to one
particular class of mammals and I think
humans potentially have some of the
building blocks that we could use to
induce hibernation because of our body
mass we could not lower our body
temperature to the points that a rodent
does and be able to rewarm at this point
I see the bear as being much more
closely related to a human type of
hibernation this is there something we
can learn about human physiology by
studying bear hibernation
well I think so and you know we've
picked a couple of topics to focus on in
our bear work and one of them is what's
known as insulin resistance it's
something that diabetics will experience
when their body's no longer respond to
insulin and so the tissues can take up
the glucose in the bloodstream
well bears undergo this process normally
when they enter hibernation and so if we
understood the mechanisms whereby they
can reverse that insulin resistance once
they come out of hibernation we might be
able to apply that to a human situation
the other thing that I think is very
interesting is this ability to lower the
metabolic rate even though the Bears are
at a relatively high body temperature
and cancer cells are very active
metabolically and so ways in which we
could turn down they're sort of
energetic usage might be a way to
to limit some of the problems associated
with with cancer
heart rates decreased tremendously
during hibernation but the Bears don't
suffer any cardiovascular problems they
have no loss of bone density they don't
lose any muscle mass in hibernation so
there's a lot of interest in trying to
understand in terms of you know people
that are bedridden or in space travel
the loss of muscle mass is considerable
but bears seem to not succumb to that
even though they're laying around for
about 98% of the day you mentioned just
there the prospect of learning to
hibernate as a way to get to Mars and I
think this is one of the sort of
interesting applications of hacking
human physiology how would hibernation
help with that effort and and how do you
see that playing out yeah the primary
benefit there is that it allows us to be
able to use a spacecraft that doesn't
require carrying all the food that's
necessary to bring someone to Mars the
passengers on the spacecraft could
actually enter that state of hibernation
and so be transported for who knows how
long maybe a couple of months even
without having to eat anything you'd
require less oxygen so you probably
wouldn't need as much oxygen on board of
course oxygen is light so that's not as
big an issue and as we could lower our
temperatures we would save even more
energy what would human hibernation look
like and why can't we hibernate already
you would essentially be asleep your
brain activity would be sleep like your
blood pressure would be lowered and your
your use of energy much like what
happens during sleep would also be
greatly reduced now when we go to sleep
our metabolic rate drops by about 6
percent or so plus or minus but
hibernation is is a much deeper level of
metabolic suppression and those are the
the targets in the pathways that we want
to try to identify what makes it
possible to go from a 6 percent
reduction in metabolic rate to a 75
percent reduction in metabolic rate it
may involve some lowering of body
temperature and that's fine those kinds
of temperatures are actually used now in
humans for surgery
and for doing organ preservation and
transplantation we know that you know by
storing something at a colder
temperature actually allows it to
actually survive for a prolonged period
of time there are of course limits to
that but I think that the principle
there is going to be very similar so is
this is this feasible I think once we
have a mechanistic picture of what's
going on and the genes and the proteins
that we identify are there in humans
then I think it is feasible we don't
have a lot of evidence to suggest that
hibernation is induced by one particular
thing right it's not there's this factor
that appears suddenly the animal goes
into hibernation it's it's malleable
it's flexible and it relies on multiple
types of events occurring and I think as
long as those pieces are there in humans
then we could translate that into a
situation where hibernation could be
induced now you know the question is
would anyone would we want to hibernate
for six months if we weren't going
somewhere right and I think the answer
is no unless it had some some obvious
benefits and I could envision for
example you know maybe someday being
able to put someone into a state of
hibernation that has a terminal disease
and maybe halting the spread of that
disease or the development of that
disease until the cure is found you know
these are all more or less science
fiction things at this point in time but
I think having that ability would get us
one step closer to being able to do
those sorts of things
now whether all the organs would survive
something like that you know these are
all the questions that remain unanswered
thinking about humans hibernating seems
super science fictiony is this a new
idea because of the sort of ambition to
go to space or is this something that
people have been thinking about for a
long time
this idea has been around for a really
long time I mean you see it in movies
going back to the 50s but what's changed
over time is the development of
molecular genetic and other tools that
allow us or will or potentially could
allow us to modulate or modify our own
physiology and those kind of things back
in the day we're all science fiction and
neither science fact and it's wrapped up
in a lot of ethical issues rightfully so
and so we need to be careful but I think
the basic premise has been there for a
long time and I think we just we're
getting closer and closer with the
development of these tools and I think
by incorporating what we learned from
from animals as we've done so often we
can apply that to humans to great
benefit who knows where this is going to
lead us we're still at a very basic
stage of trying to understand at the
very molecular level what is really
going on and what allows these
transitions to occur and so you know
taking that information to the next
level is going to be a very very
difficult progress process well thank
you so much for joining us well thank
you for having me
[Music]